michel fourniret est arrivé à 9h30 ce
matin dans cette petite rue de saint cyr
les colons rue qui est resté bloqué une
bonne partie de la journée par des
barrages de la gendarmerie
il était donc très difficile
d'apercevoir michel fourniret alors sa
venue ici un est évidemment pas un
hasard parce que c'est là dans une des
maisons de cette rue qu'il a vécu
pendant plusieurs années avec son ex
épouse monique olivier
les enquêteurs sont restés ici pendant
environ 1h30 ce matin et puis cet après
midi michel fourniret toujours encadrés
par un important dispositif de forces de
l'ordre s'est rendu dans les alentours
de la commune de saint cyr les colons
alors le butin de cette journée n'était
pas de réaliser une reconstitution au
sens propre du terme mais plutôt de
raviver des souvenirs faire une remise
en situation pour tenter de répondre à
cette question qu est il arrivé à marie
angèle domèce cette jeune femme de 19
ans disparu en 1988 et dont le corps n'a
jamais été retrouvé
il y à sept mois michel fourniret était
passé aux aveux il avait reconnu l'avoir
tuée
alors aujourd'hui les enquêteurs ont
tenté de comprendre d'obtenir des
précisions sur les circonstances exactes
de ce drame
cette journée aura-t-elle permis de
faire avancer l'enquêté
pour l'instant rien n'a filtré tout est
gardé secret